foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the short
documentary gorilla habeas by Betsy
Hershey and Emma Wall special thanks to
our lead sponsor hifa and our virtual
screening partner Vision media and now
please welcome our guests the directors
of gorilla habeas Betsy Hershey and Emma
wall thank you much for uh so much for
joining us today you too
thank you for having us
we have
a lot of film independent members who
are aspiring filmmakers and so I usually
like to start with a question about how
our filmmakers became filmmakers so why
don't we start with Betsy
yes
um so I out of college made my first
film
um I had friends who were going through
the family separation
um because of undocumented immigration
and
we decided together to record their
story and and make a film and I
I think I went to Best Buy at the time I
mean it was all very relaxed bought a
camera
um and we were just you know Off to the
Races
so
we didn't know how it was going to
unfold of course as with so many
documentaries but
um we just knew that we wanted to tell
the story and
shine a light on what they were going
through as a family because of course so
many other people were going through the
same thing and still are
that's a very direct way into filmmaking
I love it
uh I think I too went to Best Buy and
bought a camera at one point in my in my
20s
um I didn't end up becoming a
documentary filmmaker but
now I do this I talked to documentary
filmmakers instead it's incredible how
you know the equipment has changed and
made it so accessible to so many so I
think the world is a better place
because of it
uh for you Emma how did you become a
filmmaker
so uh I still kind of can't wrap my head
around the term I feel uh you know it's
so new this is my first film
um and uh I am a trained uh psychiatrist
and I specialize in child psychiatry and
that's kind of been the world that I've
known
um and through that work I've done
I've had a
you know an interest and
um really focused on trauma survivors
and working with refugees so I've worked
in refugee camps I've worked in
hospitals in South Africa I worked with
child detainees straight out of college
uh in the West Bank and Gaza so uh
Palestinian children that have been held
in detention
um and so it's just been this kind of
through line and each time I was in
these settings
I felt uh really kind of uh overwhelmed
by the suffering and the Injustice and
the kind of lack of resources uh you
know I think
um I felt kind of I didn't know how to
share the stories and really make a
difference because it was so challenging
to kind of tackle these huge problems
and so
I I was trying to kind of think of a
different way to make an impact uh and
uh and during the
kind of Crisis uh in our you know
immigration system which has you know
been challenged and and over burdened
for decades uh but there was a kind of
period of time in 2018 2019 you know
post-muslim ban you know the zero
tolerance policy when children were
being separated from their families that
uh that I just kind of was like I can't
stand by and I don't know how to do
I don't know how to be helpful but uh I
need to try and figure something out and
I was at home with a young child and I
was pregnant awaiting my next one and
and Betsy I knew had made films uh in
this area and worked in similar kind of
uh with similar issues and so
we we reached out to someone we knew who
was kind of doing this work in uh one of
the lawyers and uh and it kind of just
on You Know It All Happened uh kind of
very quickly the first
shot of the film was the first day we
went to go meet the lawyers and meet the
families and like when you are in that
setting meeting the the trauma and the
pain uh it was just like okay we have to
figure this out we have to follow this
we have to go you know get a new camera
we've got to like figure out how to use
this these uh these things and and uh
and so yeah so I think
it was really a way of trying to find a
different way to make an impact that
could reach a larger larger audience and
hopefully stem problems at the root of
the problem right so so that we could
prevent the trauma that we can prevent
the suffering uh by having more Humane
policies uh in place not only in this
country but around the world I mean this
is a global problem
um and so yeah so so I'm still kind of
uh can't believe
uh that I've you know been had the
fortune to kind of be able to share this
story and call myself a filmmaker it's
been really uh a really kind of moving
and inspiring Journey
so there's a a point an interesting
point made in the film that basically
none of our ancestors that came through
Ellis Island had to face any of the
immigration restrictions that people
face now
um because they didn't exist
so
it feels like there's a common
perception in the United States or a
misperception in the United States that
immigration laws have nobody seems to
understand that immigration laws
have changed understand who changed them
understand you know how exactly they
were changed why do you think that's so
in the dark for us why is it not
transparent
is it by Design
I think that so much of the yeah the
things that are in the dark in regards
to the immigration system are definitely
intentional and by Design
um
even just when you look at the current
situation
um you know when we were making the film
we were
so devastated to you know to see all the
ways that they're keeping
the facts hidden keeping you know
keeping cameras out of Courts keeping
cameras out of detention centers
um
they were retaliating against
um
people who had been in document
immigration documentaries
so that's like a whole another level of
invisibility that that is so so
intentional
um and it was one of the most
you know scary and shocking
realizations when making this film
because we so many of the cases that we
followed and so many incredible families
and people that we met we you know we
weren't able to
include in the in the film uh for fear
of retaliation and to of course protect
them and keep them safe
uh I have a friend who's uh whose son is
in a college class about about global
immigration
and
he was telling us that um
some countries in Europe like the UK and
Denmark have outsourced
some of their immigration issues to
countries like Rwanda
so they've made a deal with them to
basically ship out
some of their immigrants to Rwanda do
you see and then you know of course is
the example of Australia who did I don't
know if they currently do
ship all of their
immigrants to detainment camps on other
Islands surrounding Australia
do you see the United States resorting
to Solutions
I say quote unquote Solutions I don't
think they're really Solutions but do
you see the United States trying to
Resort or is there any talk that United
States has going to resort to
measures like this
I mean I think you're totally right and
and your you know friend who's in this
class this is a global problem right so
so you know migration levels are higher
than they've ever been I think last year
the numbers were there were about 280
million migrants in the world uh over 90
million displaced people uh so kind of
people either choosing to leave versus
people literally having to flee you know
whether it's uh War conflict uh climate
you know that's a huge Factor that's
just going to be increasing the number
of people uh who are seeking you know
more habitable places on this Earth and
and you know many of the places that
have been made uninhabitable when you
look at you know Pakistan and the
massive flooding happening happening
there
you know I can't remember the the
numbers but it's like their contribution
to kind of overall Greenhouse uh
greenhouse gases or climate things I
think it was like one percent
um and then you know so you have the
countries who are really kind of uh
behind a lot of the forces uh driving
these migration uh uh patterns not you
know at the same time building walls up
against the people who are seeking
Refuge
um and you know that kind of Rise that
we're seeing around the world of kind of
populist governments that are really
kind of promoting this xenophobic uh and
you know uh often very racist kind of
rhetoric
um you know is is so
ah yeah it is is is awful and and the
thing that happens when you see those
migration patterns and displacement
patterns is the impact on families right
so families get separated in that path
there was an incredible film I'm you may
have seen last year uh called flee that
was a Danish documentary about you know
and seeing those children and those
family members all being trapped in
different countries as they're seeking
uh you know refuge and safety is uh is
something that's happening just on a
global scale and I think is something
you know that we view our film as kind
of a case study it's set in the U.S but
it's just kind of one story of family
child separation in the context of kind
of really This Global crisis
um and so uh
yeah I think it's a you know it's an
issue that in the United States we're
not managing well right I think there's
uh you know the zero tolerance policy
where people were you know at Trump they
were literally
separating children intentionally losing
them in the system not recording uh
their whereabouts I mean their children
still who have not been reunited with
their families uh there's these stay in
Mexico you know policy which I think is
not totally dissimilar it's you know
seeking asylum in this country is a
legal right it is legal to seek Asylum
and so this idea of kind of illegal
immigrants you know and it's kind of is
it legal is it not legal you know should
we be housing them here versus kind of
shipping them out to other places uh
uh you know I think it's one of the
wealthiest countries in the world like
we should be able to do better
um and and it's really heartbreaking to
see how many governments around the
world uh in some of the wealthiest
countries are treating uh families uh so
inhumanely and the impact
developmentally on children you know
separating them in that way uh kind of
causing that kind of Primal type of
trauma is uh is just devastating and
something that we hope people talk more
about the kind of the need to keep
families together need to support them
uh the need to kind of not be uh sending
people to places uh that are not where
they have you know sought to go
yeah it's uh it's crazy I was talking
about this with a friend of mine and uh
you know I live in Los Angeles where
there's thousands of unhoused people
right now
um
and I guess it's not you know
it's shocking but not shocking because
we don't even want to do anything to
help the people who need help inside our
own country so it's kind of not shocking
that we don't want to do anything to
help people coming from outside
um
but it's interesting the Paradigm shifts
because we view we have viewed you know
immigration from the past with the warm
fuzzy feeling like that's the founding
of our country
but we can't seem to view it that way
anymore we can only view it as a burden
on our own system
um
do you
feel
well let me just ask what do you what do
you hope to take away from your film is
when people watch it
I think our biggest hope is for people
to have an emotional experience while
watching the film because I think from
that experience we can create change
from having that Human Experience of
understanding the impact this is having
on humans and families and children
um
I hope that that will activate people in
the way that
suits them the best whether it's
supporting people and organizations who
are doing this important work
um to fight back against this broken
system or if if it's
um campaigning and voting for
politicians who are working on
immigration reform or supporting some of
these families that are being torn apart
um in some way shape or form whether
it's through organizations or otherwise
um that would be the you know the
ultimate dream for us
yeah I mean there's bills you know in
Congress right now like basic things
like you know there is not Universal
representation in the Immigration Court
System right so when we think of
of Courts you know I think I walked into
the the film thinking well you know
certainly people have the right to a
lawyer and that's not the case in uh in
the Immigration Court System they don't
have the right to see a judge they don't
have the right to see uh to have a
lawyer if they can't provide one
themselves and that applies even to
children so there are literally like
toddlers in court uh in a foreign
country in a foreign language
representing themselves in court the US
government feels that that's appropriate
so there's a Bill in Congress right now
saying you know that probably doesn't
make a lot of sense and you know I think
a lot of people can agree that that
children should be afforded lawyers if
they cannot you know they cannot provide
one themselves uh particularly when so
many of them are fleeing real life and
death consequences and so uh so there
are things that we can do you know I
think kind of the sweet big immigration
reform that you know hasn't happened uh
is you know tragic but there are little
individual steps there's a bill right
now about moving the immigration courts
out of the executive branch where it is
now where it's really just under the
power of the president to kind of do
whatever they want with the policies uh
and move it into the judicial branch uh
where you can at least hope uh where
there at least traditionally has been a
measure of objectivity and kind of you
know uh
um a hope that they would have an
impartial judge uh be able to try their
cases so so there are these little ways
which you know I think we uh really hope
to see uh people feel connected to the
issue who can kind of
say like Sheriff Apple you know who's
this kind of law enforcement agent who
isn't the kind of typical Ally you would
see for two immigration lawyers who are
saying this isn't right you know this is
not what uh this is not the gang members
and the criminals that they're being
labeled as by politicians that we need
to kind of get rid of from this country
these are you know these are people with
families these are individuals who are
paying taxes who have jobs who have
communities uh who are literally being
disappeared kind of out of nowhere
um and so uh kind of taking steps to
kind of say you know that's not my
concept of what this country
uh represents or those do not reflect
that doesn't reflect my values I mean
you know I want everyone who sees this
film to kind of come to their own
conclusions and and have their own
experience but uh but certainly kind of
asking the questions of like did I you
know uh is this how I would want things
to be and if not kind of
voting or volunteering or donating uh
whatever whatever they can kind of feel
uh another interesting aspect of your
film is that you not only talk about the
work
of
um you know
um these court cases of trying to get
people to be able to stay in the United
States you you speak about
um the or the organization that you're
talking about who's doing this rapid
defense network
you're also speaking about the toll that
it's taking on the two people that run
the rapid defense network which is for
one of them at least Greg Copeland's a
massive toll
um do you want to talk about why you
thought that was really important to
show the effect on
U.S citizens trying to help immigrants
stay here
I think it's such an important excuse me
I think it's such an important
aspect for us to all understand about
our society
um
that
people doing this work people who are
willing to give it they're all you know
aren't being supported and don't have
the support that they need to
in so many cases keep going because like
we see in the film with Gregory burning
out
um it just wasn't sustainable for him
and I mean I want to live in a society
where we're helping the people the
helpers we're helping the helpers and
we're
um
where people who are willing to fight
against the system that's so broken are
being supported and they don't have to
choose you know All or Nothing basically
um and it's a I think it's a rare
individual
who could who could make that choice
um so I think it's really a societal
issue and it's again something that I'm
hoping people will will reflect upon and
ask you know is this the way that I want
our world to work
in our country and around the world
right
was so is rapid defense network
um a non-profit organization that that
survives on donations is that what the
issue is
yeah so uh so they are a two-person you
know uh or they were at the start of the
film a kind of a two-person team
um and they realized that there was this
huge unmet need that people uh you know
uh working in some of the bigger
organizations the kind of national you
know ones that we've all heard of uh
there's you know with any kind of big
bureaucracy there's red tape and there's
rules I know you can't do this and you
can't do that and they were in this
situation where they were like we want
to do everything we possibly can we're
gonna try and pull rabbits out of hats
because the stakes are so high and so
we're gonna do things in ways that you
know maybe people don't normally do them
and we might break some rules you know
calling in at the side of uh of a
highway and and doing a you know hearing
over the phone but it worked and so that
kind of uh their you know commitment to
kind of doing whatever it takes and
trying new strategies and being willing
to lose or being willing to you know
humiliate themselves in front of a judge
because you know there are they're not
winning was a kind of was what they felt
was what they were willing to do because
they wanted to help families however
they could and so
they basically you know they had no
funding they had no offices they had no
staff
um and they were kind of drinking from
like a fire hose of you know the number
of people who needed their help because
they started winning these cases and
they were becoming really successful
they were changing the way that people
were using the law to fight against
illegal uh deportation and detention and
so they were looking for funding they
were applying they were kind of doing
everything they could they were asking
for for donations and that was kind of
you know what they were supporting
themselves on I think they were you know
supporting themselves on their own
personal savings and you know Gregory
was having to sell his apartment and you
know uh and and at a certain point it
just you know it couldn't continue after
you know a couple of years of of just
trying to do that and that's I think
what was so kind of sad to us because
they were so successful and they were
doing things in this way that was doing
such good work and there's just such
little funding and support for these
communities and the people supporting
these communities uh it's so under
resource and they're all kind of uh you
know the organizations in these fields
are you know they're all fighting for
this very small allocation of funding
from you know Public Funding and donors
and so so ultimately
um
you know it just it couldn't keep going
and that you know that's such a a sad I
mean Sarah obviously continued it on but
I think kind of as a as a team also the
emotional toll that it took on Gregory I
mean that was something I think his one
of his main reasons like uh you know the
it takes a really singular uh type of
person you know as a psychiatrist too I
experienced burnout
um working in you know settings with
children uh when you
when you can't help people in the way
that you dream of helping them when you
have to be the container for so much
suffering and uh Injustice uh it's it's
really you know it's it's worked for the
people living the trauma uh but it's
also uh a challenge for those trying to
support and so finding that way to like
as a you know group if if you're willing
to be a pro bono lawyer you know after
with all of your debt from law school
and whatever it is you're willing to go
out there and and and work for you know
no money and and uh and put in those
hours and to at least have the basic you
know covering their costs covering their
office space getting them you know a
student that can support them just those
those basic things I think uh you know
are things that would be
would serve so many families if if we
could kind of find a way of prioritizing
um some of that support
so rapid defense network still exists
um is there a way for just like regular
people to support them do they take like
private donations and
do they have like a website and
yeah yeah
so they basically separated you know
ways Sarah one of the lawyers continued
on and then literally just like a month
or two ago I don't actually know the
exact details but she merged uh her kind
of organization of one
um with uh RFK human rights and has now
become their kind of you director of U.S
litigation and so she has kind of Taken
rapid defense network the clients that
she's serving the work that they've been
doing and kind of integrated it under
this umbrella
um organization where
um where she's kind of continuing to do
the same work and really kind of expand
take those take that work and expand it
um so I think it's like super exciting
so certainly you know supporting her
work at RFK human rights is an option
and then uh
uh and then there are lots of you know
there are other you know immigrant you
know support uh organizations all over
the country because obviously
um these challenges are facing
communities all over the country so
um but yeah but so to support Sarah and
like in her work and the clients that
she's working with
um you can do that directly through uh
RFK human rights
great
so did Gregory stay in this work or did
he start like a Basset Hound Rescue
his dogs his dogs were like you should
ask that he yeah he's not currently
practicing but he is he is living
Upstate with his dogs and
um I think other other pets but we you
know as such fans of his hope that he'll
find a way back into helping people
again one day
well thanks so much to the two of you
for coming in and talking to us about
about your film today
um I wish you the best of success do you
think that the two of you will keep
making films
um in this area of documentary in
immigration reform
I think we're definitely going to keep
working together and I think you know we
both kind of have worked in this in this
field before I think almost kind of
I think there's a few different ideas
almost macroscoping up even further to
the issue of kind of
the climate influence uh you know is
also something we've been kind of
talking about so I think I think we both
feel committed to to continuing to work
on kind of things that we feel are
Urgent problems uh that we want to
somehow uh Castle light on shine a light
on
um kind of
overcome the sense of hopelessness and
helplessness that we felt by finding
people who kind of can hopefully restore
some hope and a pathway of like you know
what can be done and like not giving up
and uh that I think is that's the goal
for me is just kind of and you know for
work going forward is like how can we
continue to do things that help uh
kind of uh
move things in the right direction
well great absolutely and thank you so
much for having us Jen it's been so
lovely to chat with you thank you I'm so
glad that I got the opportunity to see
the film and talk with you it's
definitely a really interesting
conversation and inspiring film
thank you thank you thanks
[Music]